well today is a good time to think about
kicking the habit it is the great
american smoke out a day to challenge
yourself
to quit bianca holman live on the las
vegas strip where there's been some
non-smoking changes in recent months hi
bianca good morning
hey good morning alex and good morning
everybody at home matter of fact
when it came to september and park mgm
reopened they became an entirely
smoke-free property
and also there have been other
properties around the las vegas
boulevard that have
expanded their smoke-free zone so now
could be the
great time for lots of people to kick
that habit so the cdc estimates nearly
16 percent of adults in nevada are
cigarette smokers
smoking is the leading cause of stroke
cancer and heart disease that's why
today the great american smoke out is so
important
the annual challenge was started by the
american cancer society
as a way to get smokers to take one day
off experts say you should come up with
a plan
set a goal and consider things like
nicotine gum or counseling and remember
not to give up the first time doesn't
always work
so i think what we do as the american
cancer society is encourage you
to try and try again
the american cancer society has a ton of
great tips for quitting
and also to help you again quit the
habit
there is a guide on their website it's
called cancer.org that's their website
and there's a guide to help you take
those first steps
towards kicking that habit reporting
live in las vegas boulevard bianca
coleman 8 news now